nos moments de type de personne le type
de personne qui pense que la venue et la
fin de tout à coup nous les connaissons
et les personnes qui voient l'avenir
comme une berceuse plein de possibilités
et de technologies avancées
aujourd'hui je suis ici peut expliquer
comment les deux réseaux hta de l'avenir
sombre est à certains égards
je vais parler des percées
technologiques médicaux la nourriture et
les chargements en l'environnement
est-ce que vous avez quelque chose comme
un ordinateur ou un téléphone que vous
ne buvez pas vivre sans je sais que si
dans les années 50 en oeuvre l'évolution
des micro-ordinateurs tenant tenait et
de l'avant cellulaire temps de bercy
technologie conçue prétend qu est-ce qui
cela dit à propos des 50 années qui
suivent deux morts la graphie il y as
presque dans la pub lic été introduit à
l'agrafer un matériau qui peuvent
apparemment changé notre mode de vie
la raffinerie est étrange c'est très
fort mais très flexible et légère en
même temps c'est presque comme un
graphique assez fait avec les atomes du
gabon mais les différends se règlent
raphaël et comment les atolls du gabon
sont liés ensemble chaque thé atomique
est disposée en pointe du hexagone
certains pensent qu'il semble com com du
fils a pu les sifi atomiques sont trop
forts qui peuvent tenir un masque
quelque chose comme un ballon de basket
qu'on a graffé les tyrans du public en
2002 nous étions promis beaucoup de
méthodes utiles comme le meur baballe
les six recrues en café les avions
autres les jarres et quelques uns qui
sont un peu plus étranges comme un
ascenseur à la lune mais où sont ses
intentions
c était un progrès depuis 2002 croyez le
ou non elles sont un progrès pendant que
nous parlons c'est procès et langue est
puissant mais c'est pas ce que nous
allons voir ses projets un progrès
pendant le prochain cinquantenaire
quand la technologie continue à
s'avancer plus en plus occupés par les
machines plus souvent les emplois dans
les usines si surtout parce que c'est
pratique et moins cher il y a des gens
qui pensent que les machines croyait le
chômage mais je trouve que c'est le
contraire tu l'aimés chine ont besoin
d'un créateur se spécialise tenu par
l'auteur est quelqu'un qui les install
même si les technologies remplacer
emploi ils ont créé à d'autres en même
temps nous allons passer à mon prochain
point les médicaments la venue de les
médicaments sera toujours le plus grand
mystère mais nous avons constamment de
nouveaux percée en 2010 c'est un nouveau
prototype été créé pour les vaccinations
c'est presque comme un pansement avec
tes petits micros et geek ici 18 là ce
que cela impliquait que le prototype est
sorti on va voir un grand changement en
92 personnes qui obtient les
vaccinations
car c'est une autre actif un dollar avec
plus de personnes qui obtient les
vaccinations vivre en plein temps qui
est ma vie n est ce pas en réalité c'est
un grand problème plus longtemps
convives pouvaient risquer les
défaillances de vaud à gand mais il ya
solution en 2011 le monde était
introduit l idée d orgue en imprimé en
3d si je rédige en remplacement de gand
était difficile au passé mais à l'avenir
nous allons avoir la kabylité d'imprimer
le corps décret une fois et barbe du
corps en quelques heures il y à des
personnes qui pensent que les autres ont
imprimé un toit des ventes dans les
lieux en population du mesa difficiel ou
essentiellement les dominateurs oui les
gens vu plein temps mais connaissez vous
commencez à jouer on ne peut venir
remplacer sur le sujet d or ont imprimé
un toit de la nourriture en premier et
wade est quelque chose avec lequel les
scientifiques se sont ingérés qu'on ne
m'en devient plus pas pu les nus devant
trouver des moyens poids comme à dire
des personnes en 18 18 l'interné et y
est donné avec les at il écrit sur du
bifteck en premier en 3d
bifteck sont imprimées avec les
protéines des légumes et est extrait
comme le bifteck
c'est l'entreprise est petit mais non
mais ça va être une grande partie de nos
vies pas dix mille cinq ans même avec
les crayons heures c'est possible que
les différents biens comme le boeuf vont
être considéré quelque chose pour les
riches
le problème maintenant est la
surpopulation aussitôt que la population
continue à grossir le matin de déchets
vont un peu la même chose cela ma mère -
point final les chargements un
environnement notre monde et un procès
d'être complètement détruit portes ici
produits en plastique citer qu'eux mais
si lisez les semences 62 ans et on ne
vous déjà les montées du plastique
autour du mans pas 2050 on va produire
15 me produire 900 millions trop de
plastiques chacun et va voir le
plastique le sien que les poissons la
pêche aux déchets nous sommes pas
amusant de tueur
ce n'est pas son nom les organismes
aquatiques et va souffrir qu'est ce
bilan d'att pour ne s'occuper chacun et
6,6 détruit des milliers d'habitations
ce procédé
contrairement à mes autres au point nous
voulons pas de changement et avec notre
foi ça va se réaliser
réduisez réutilisez recyclez et à vos
boîtes de grands changements et même
s'il ya tant de possibilités
extraordinaires à l'avenir nul ne
saurait jamais ceux qui avons très hâte
de notre monde
merci
[Applaudissements]